i woke up and i said to my daughter
we're gonna buy a watch and she's like
why are we gonna buy a watch i said well
because i have to collapse the wave
function and she's like what the heck
does that mean dad whenever i feel this
anxiety and i have this big challenge
coming up
most people would sort of like go for
the idea of if i achieve something i'm
gonna give myself the reward i decided
to put the card in front of the horse
and give myself the reward because i
understood that embodying and being the
thing i wanted to achieve was tantamount
to actually achieving it i bought this
really nice watch and it was a a reward
for having overcome in the future
the thing i hadn't achieved yet damn
every time i look at my watch i'm gonna
remember the thing that i've already
achieved
as if it had already happened
[Music]
hello welcome to the pretty intense
podcast today
might be the pinnacle of intense robert
edward grant definitely pushed my limits
of what i uh of my intelligence keeping
up
uh i feel like i might have listened to
this about five times before half the
concepts really sink in he is a very
successful entrepreneur he tells stories
about you know having a unicorn company
which for those who don't know it means
a billion dollar company before he ever
went past a seed round he's also a
best-selling author his area of
expertise is in math and in particular
patterns
so
the conversation was very esoteric it
was very much about the scientific
roots of our existence
so we looked at everything from music
to pyramids
to
patterns in our reality um
psychologically
and how that relates to
the greater universe and essentially our
purpose here which we talk about at the
end
um
so yeah very enlightening conversation i
think that there are some people that
come
to
this planet this
realm of existence that just are here to
further our path and to
uh anchor new new realities for us and
and um
new paradigms of existence and robert's
definitely one of them so i was so
excited to get him on the show
please enjoy the show
listen as many times as it takes because
i think that there are a lot of concepts
in here that we really um
so many of us really anybody could
benefit from enjoy the episode please
hit subscribe it really tells me that
you're enjoying the content and uh these
interviews are resonating with you and i
would love to hear what you think in the
comments oh i'm so excited to talk to
you
oh my god
really i i can't imagine that you're as
excited as i am i'm flattered but i'm
i'm gonna i'm i'm gonna say that i win
well my excitement i'm i'm flattered by
you saying that um but i've been you
know seeing you on tv and everything for
the probably the past i don't know
15 years or something so it's it's a
pleasure to meet you
man there's so many areas that you
talk about and touch on that are like
totally my daily fascinations like
you know
what is reality
what is consciousness like how are the
pyramids built
what is time
small questions small questions though
those are gigantic questions i think and
i shared those same questions too that's
really i think it was probably the seat
of my curiosity
and why i kind of wanted to start
studying and learning as much about this
there was something like
kind of a soul-level curiosity that
caused me to ask those exact same
questions and i think that's probably
what you're experiencing
do you remember what the first question
was that really kind of like
got you researching you know i was
always fascinated by the pyramids but i
would say the
the real first questions were more about
physics
i wanted to understand you know what is
the nature of the universe i was
i think tiring a little bit of this it
just wasn't fulfilling enough this
notion of materiality
and what is materialism
and i felt like there was something more
and probably quantum physics
was probably an introduction i'd say
probably about
2008 when what the bleep do we know came
out on uh on youtube someone pointed me
to it and i was like wait a minute and i
already knew about some of the
principles of heisenberg's uncertainty
as well as double slit phenomenon
but that's when i really started to
question
the role that my own mind was playing in
the experience i was experiencing
and i started seeing more and more
connections between
what i was expecting to see and what i
would see
aha explain more i mean this is like
manifestation this is kind of like how
you create your reality thoughts become
things
yeah i think all of the above um you
know this idea that
maybe the observer plays a role
in what is actually observed
and that was probably as a result of of
learning in depth about the double slit
phenomenon quantum eraser and other
things that kind of come along with that
i was starting and i'm sure you as an
athlete
um knew that when you could visualize
things
and probably before you did a race you
probably
went through the race many times through
your mind
and visualize
yeah and you visualize it most great
athletes are able to do that very easily
it's like a natural thing for them and i
i wasn't an athlete per se but in
business and in life i had always
practiced this art of manifestation and
i would call it like collapsing the wave
function
yeah just casually i just called it
collapsing the wave function well i'll
give you an example so i used to i used
to collect watches i don't anymore i
think the notion and the importance of
time has probably diminished in my
mindset over the last several years so i
don't i used to collect tons of watches
and
whenever i would have a moment of fear
or anxiety about something coming up
that i was concerned
needed to go really well or you know i
felt like i was living on the edge of a
knife right from a risk perspective like
usually always calculated risk it wasn't
like i was going to vegas and gambling
you know putting it all on on you know
21 or something like that right on on a
roulette wheel
but
what it was for me is when i feel this
moment of anxiety and i remember in 2014
i was in shanghai china with my daughter
and i woke up one morning and i was like
oh gosh you know this company that i'd
founded that became a unicorn like very
quickly within two years it was on a run
rate of 200 million dollars in sales
what was the company uh the company was
called alfion it's now the second
largest
uh healthcare lender in the united
states oh wow wow and and so
i remember thinking though i needed to
raise money at that time and i was like
we're going to take the company public
and i have to do a series a and the
series b and all the other stuff wait
you got to be a unicorn company before
you even raise the series a or b yeah
well actually the series a the series a
i knew i was going into it our we did a
a
very large seed round and the seed round
was about 250 million dollars oh my god
oh my god that's insignificant and then
we did a our series a was 700 million
pre-money and our series b was 1. 1.1
billion
and isn't a unicorn a billion dollar
company a billion dollars yeah so i was
but the series a and the series b
happened within you know only less than
a year of each other so it was all
around the same time and i knew it was
coming up and we were going to take the
company public and i needed to get
you know kind of like a series a and
series be done even though we didn't
really need the capital
we needed the validation so that we
could get to the public markets but then
ultimately we didn't get to go to the
public market because uh the market
basically collapsed during 2016 there
were no ipos done
and so i went through like a really
difficult time as a result of that but
that's a whole other part of the story
but what i was doing when i was in
shanghai's i was knowing that i was
facing this thing and i didn't like the
idea of having to go get venture capital
money just to get the validation
right on valuation the company was
growing leaps and bounds very successful
we went from zero to a thousand
employees in 18 months like it was it
was crazy all over the world and
what happened
was i woke up and i said to my daughter
i'm like sweetheart we're going to go
to the bulgari store bulgari
and we're going to buy a watch and she's
like why are we going to buy a watch and
i said she's like 18 years old at the
time and i said well because i have to
collapse the wave function
and she's like what the heck does that
mean dad
and i said well
what it is is whenever i feel this
anxiety and i have this big challenge
coming up
most people would sort of like go for
the idea of i if i achieve something i'm
going to give myself the reward
right
and so i decided to put the card in
front of the horse
and give myself the reward because i
understood that embodying and being the
thing i wanted to achieve was tantamount
to actually achieving it
right so i would buy watches because how
many times you look at your watch a day
that was the only reason why i would do
it and i would buy this really expensive
watch that i've been kind of like
aspiring to have and everything when i
was still stuck in my material world
type of thing
and i would buy this watch so i bought
this really nice watch and it was a a
reward for having overcome in the future
the thing i hadn't achieved yet damn
and it was a burn the ship's mentality
you've heard this story about uh you
know cortez going to mexico with
terrible conquistador type activity but
what he did that was kind of crazy
genius
uh i'm not putting any morals behind
what he actually did to like you know
take over the nation or take over the
land from the indigenous peoples but
what he did that was kind of crazy was
he had 300 men and i think it was six
ships
and they're in this bay and they all
went to kind of go to the bathroom and
they come back out onto the beach and
they look and they see all their ships
on
fire and they're like how did all our
ships get on fire and cortez looks like
he says
well there won't be any other ships
coming from spain for another year
there's 300 of us and there's three
million of them
and we have to survive this i burned the
ships
there's no going back
oh god he like it was a forced he forced
the situation he forced the situation
he's like we're here to conquer and to
win
and to a certain extent you know that
was probably the stage of my life when i
was like very much in that
material mode of you know winning and
and succeeding and all of that and i
thought okay i'll buy a watch i'll
collapse the wave function every time i
look at my watch i'm gonna remember the
thing that i've already achieved
as if it had already happened yeah and i
found it was very successful
and i could do that i could collapse a
wave function but that was the earlier
stage and i didn't really that's the
time that i still believe that
i could make things happen in the world
and now i realized you know having gone
through my own spiritual path is that
yes that was sort of like me playing
with myself in what's called leela
and leela is this notion of maya
or samsara which is
you are playing with yourself to make
you believe in a way
that it was you all along that came up
with this and
you know there wasn't a such thing in my
world as destiny i believed in free will
it was all about free will you know you
make it happen you know there are three
types of people i used to say this all
the time three types of people in the
world
people that like some people make things
happen
some people watch things happen and
other people wonder what the hell just
happened
and and i would definitely be in the
mindset of i'm a make it happen kind of
person probably like yourself i would
bet yeah i was going to say that i agree
with that yeah and and so i i really
discounted any optionality or any
notion that there could be a destiny
involved
and that maybe
what i call destiny i later learned
might actually just be the free will of
the higher self
is this operating separately from us
well not separately it's it's working
through us but it is the first stop what
is that part that observer you talked
about the observer at first and
you know i have kind of been been in
those spaces before where i've been been
able to be the observer and in fact more
and more in my life just walking through
life becoming more of the observer of
things instead of feeling things so
personally it's just things happening um
but what what is what is it that you're
explaining then with this observer with
this sort of
higher self i just got done having a
discussion with aubry marcus
and you know i'm i'm in austin right now
and i was just with aubry and we're
talking about hermeticism and the first
principle of the seven principles of her
medicine there you go
i read it i grabbed it because i was
like i had heard that you had about
hermeticism listening to stuff before i
talked to you and i was like i read this
book it's fantastic it's a vibe it's
definitely a vibe and actually that's
the third law or the third principle of
hermeticism is vibration law of
vibration but
the very first principle and each of
these principles tied to the chakras
right we're born the root is born into
this world where we're conditioned to
believe it's like the construct of this
world is is conditioned to make you
believe in a way that everything is
about material it's solid you can count
on this thing right you're born in this
world of separation and you know you
have this separation and then fear
creeps in and all the other aspects that
then we decide what are the things that
bring us shame and those are the things
i don't want to be
and the things that don't bring us shame
are the things that i want to ascribe to
i want to show the world that i am that
thing and then as we get older we start
to want to align more and more with that
perfection
and not see the other aspects of
ourselves that we repress entirely
yeah the shadow self shadow the negative
aspects of ourselves
and so you know this whole idea of
mentalism is the first principle of
hermeticism
is to basically break down this
conditioned idea that by the way i
believe we all subjected ourselves to
you know think of ourselves as more in a
construct of matrix of mind where you're
in an avatar
and this avatar body right imagine that
we're making let's say you and i decided
to make a video game and the video game
was here
and it was intended to teach human
awareness and consciousness
how to expand so you'd probably come up
with some rules right and there would be
like some ground rules yeah
some you know principles that are gonna
always be lasting constants if you will
right across that game environment yeah
we want people to learn through
experience not by didactic learning we
want people to have the experience of
what it's like and the more real you
make it
the more powerful the learnings can be
yeah so you put yourself into a
situation where
you don't remember any of it
oh it's a hot stove i mean you can say
don't touch the hat so but sometimes you
gotta touch the hot stove that's right
and you don't remember that you actually
chose all of this that's part of the
game
and the whole game is intended for you
to refine yourself and remember who you
are
and so as you go through this game
you're you're learning all these aspects
of yourself you start taking on you know
i have to learn how to transcend this
notion of duality and it's not always
about black and white here's what's
right and what's wrong maybe
the objective truth is that it's the sum
of all possible perspectives
and maybe i can start learning to see
outside of the perspectives that i had
been conditioned into
and maybe those conditionings are more
predestined
in the context of when i was born in the
time i was born into and astrology and
numerology and all the other stuff
and what you're describing now is a game
that's more like a matrix of mind
and max planck
who was the
you know the physicist that i would say
was probably the mentor most of you know
possibly could be seen as the mentor of
einstein because somebody had to sponsor
einstein einstein was working as a
patent clerk in in switzerland he wasn't
going to become this huge academic nobel
laureate until somebody came along and
sponsored him in his thinking and that
was max plonk max planck was definitely
more of a quantum physicist yep
than einstein einstein was more about if
i can see it and it's there you know
there were a lot of different
philosophies at the time so if you
believe in heisenberg's uncertainty
principle and you understand the double
slip phenomenon then you would have to
ask the question wait a minute if i'm
not observing something does it even
exist
it's that concept of you know if a bear
shit's in the woods
right did it really ever happen if
nobody observed it if a tree falls then
it ever happened if no one observed it
yep so what your experience and what you
just described is going from a world of
observation equals judgment
to now a world of
observation
delayed judgment
and maybe eventually you go to the next
level as well beyond that which could be
no judgment or see it from different
perspectives this is why when people
are asked you know if they were an
eyewitness to a crime there were 30
eyewitnesses of the same crime but they
all have entirely different versions of
what happened and that is their truth
yeah and realizing that my truth is not
really the whole truth it's only one
facet of a prism we call truth
i'm very fascinated and i've been asking
various different people for a while now
if it's if there is such thing
as an objective truth
because
you know with our
our world really showing us who we are
and information about us
like can we have and we all have our own
lens is it possible
is there an objective truth and and
maybe if there is is part of this
3d matrix that we're in and this reality
that we live in is part of that
that we
we can't
we don't have we can't see that
objective truth
i think
if we could raise our consciousness to
very very high levels right and that's
one of the principles within hermeticism
in the kybaleon
and the seven hermetic principles is
that vibration determines that no matter
what happens to us you can determine
whether or not that was possibly the
worst thing that ever happened to you
based on your judgment or possibly even
the best thing that ever happened to you
how many times have you had an
experience that you thought that was the
worst thing that ever happened oh my god
it was horrible and then later on come
back to it and said gosh
that turned out to be the best thing
that ever happened i mean i've been
thinking about that as well that
really our interface with reality our
our experience of reality is really just
perception
it's a and which perception is
inevitably subjective
you know i i often say you know it's
like we i used to say well we have a
perception or perspective based on
geometry of what our vantage point is
the position from which we're seeing
something what angle am i looking at
something
well maybe the better way to say it
what if we replace the word vantage
point with advantage point
that actually our conscious minds
are looking at things and we're
justifying whatever truth we want to see
based on what we perceive as our
advantage in it
yeah it's just a perception shift it's
just a perception shift so with that i
think
what is happening with all of us is
we're all starting to wake up to
gosh and it's it's it's very distressing
right it's like the stuff i thought was
true the way i saw the world
there may be a different way of seeing
it and so then
the immediate reaction to that is going
to be to
defend the old positions
sure
right and fight vociferously for those
positions to remain because that's habit
we all sort of get into that now why do
we fight
why do we fight for the reality that we
know
i think because we get triggered with
the idea that it might not be what we
knew
i think to a certain extent you know
i'll give you an example
right right now we've got a very
polarized society i don't think anyone
can deny that right we've got geez
there's some people that are saying hey
are we gonna have like a civil war or
something who knows right i mean it's
not something most people would probably
say on a podcast but i'll say it it's
it's kind of a scary time on many levels
but also inside that might be a huge
massive silver lining of transformation
too
oh yeah well because
clearly what's going on from a system
perspective right now
i can't say that it's really working out
great you know to be honest
and for me who sits kind of in the
middle i'm not neither republican nor
democrat
as i kind of look at this
what we forget is that there is a rhythm
to all of these things what we used to
call
you know
democrat actually often transforms over
time to republican and vice versa i'll
give you one example of this 170 years
ago is not that long ago we had a civil
war
and today
you look at you know which party is more
lined with the naacp it's going to be
the democratic party without a doubt
but it was the democrats who were the
plantation owners in the south
exactly
right and it was lincoln who was a
republican who basically fought for
emancipation proclamation but then you
could also argue but wait a minute was
it really about that or was it about
northern dominance of the industrial
revolution
and unfair trade practices
was it really just about money
right you could go down lots of rabbit
holes on this
and what i would say is that
what we thought was a certain thing
is not necessarily dual
you know i have known people that are
arrogant in their humility
think about that so is arrogance in
humility really a linear juxtaposition
of each other or rather
representing two poles or rather is it
circular
oh
definitely
right and so from a philosophical
perspective that's this transition i
think we're all sort of experiencing
right now which is distressing and and
that causes us to be triggered and
really when the universe is throwing at
us triggers in this maya matrix of mine
that max planck would say
you know
in his own statement he said there is no
matter as such
right and what this really points to is
the notion of a
conscious mind
behind the universe and that's sort of
the far end probably of the thinking of
quantum physics so
in that reality it's not that we get
what we deserve per se
it's maybe we get what we expected
because our belief system actually
informs that reality around us it maybe
it's not a universe as much as it is a
you inverse
project it back it's you on the inside
projected back to you yes all the aspect
because this is your own universe right
it's your own universe
your lens of perception is your own
unique lens of perception and how you
experience that world is going to define
your reality 90 plus of what happens to
us isn't what really happened to us
what is it you've talked about before
like words coming into awareness before
like you see it in your reality and i've
had that too
how does that play into that paradigm
i'll give you a funny example
i was uh on social media and there was
this
weird and this is happening more and
more lately there was this like post of
this guy wearing a giant neck brace
and he was like sitting at a cafe he's
not able to move around but then this
pretty girl walks by
and he wrenches his neck to like look at
her right and he's like oh that hurt
and then another girl walks by and he
does it again he couldn't stop himself
and so it said like something like
something crazy like men will be you
know boys will be boys or something like
that yeah
and i was sort of laughing about that
and i then went from you know being on
social media to a call that i had with
my attorneys who were working on a
patent license agreement with me
and the attorney gets on and he's the
first thing i see is this giant neck
brace
i've never been oh my god
i've never been on a call with an
attorney with a giant neck brace he's
like
i just had surgery you know i had
compressed disc and all that i was just
like okay that's weird
now before i would have looked at that
and said
hmm
that's kind of a weird coincidence
right exactly
right now i look at it and say maybe
there are no coincidences
and maybe there's a message inside this
from my you inverse which is really my
subconscious mind and what is that
message
i don't know yet as you go further in
this process and go down this rabbit
hole you'll find more and more and more
synchronicities in the way that carl
jung described
he described the enlightenment process
or what he termed individuation
as the process of increasing
synchronicities
that whether those are they often start
as numbers that might be words
right but you'll you'll see that there's
like this subtle background almost like
a radio frequency where everything and
everyone is almost like on a new script
yeah it's like the same timeline
right
and you know because once you get tapped
into it and maybe most of us and i was
totally unaware of this
collective consciousness
until the last several years
and as i got deeper and deeper into
studying and understanding this and
really looking at the work of people
like carl jung who really just took
hermeticism and alchemy
and applied it in the contextual
framework of a scientific mindset
and that's what he did i mean that's his
whole individuation process is that but
he was an alchemist he was very much not
of the same thinking you know he took
maslow's hierarchy of needs and
added to it another layer not
self-actualization
but self-transcendence
the highest level would be
self-transcendence
or enlightenment
where you realize that
what you deem as the higher self
and your lower self here in this three
dimensional four dimensional experience
are actually not separate at all
maybe this you inverse and how you
perceive the world around you
is just an artifact of your
subconscious mind and you're being
projected back upon all the things that
you deny in yourself and then you see
them in the world around you and they
come back
as reflections until you learn one day
that the things you judged are actually
the things that you continue to attract
and once you finally get that
what we attract is what we judge until
we no longer judge what we attracted
yep the world starts to change so
being the change you see in the world
and going through
a spiritual process is not about
learning how to judge more i don't
believe we came to earth to learn how to
judge i believe we came to earth to
learn how to love
i believe we came to ur to learn how to
accept
which always starts with the self learn
how to accept and
it's an inside job so
our reality is just showing us where we
don't love ourselves exactly
so i want to talk about synchronicities
for a second because
you would mention the quote being about
increasing in in increasing
synchronicities
so
is it something that
you find a way
to create more of by being on the path
by being in alignment with your higher
self and it's like
or
are we just noticing like do you think
that
you see them saying like are we just
becoming more attuned to how the
universe speaks to us
or do we actually and maybe it's a both
maybe it's not an or it's an end
or do and or do we get on the path and
then we actually do notice them even if
we're not seeking them out we notice
them how do synchronicities work because
i think this is a language that a lot of
people are aware of but they don't quite
understand the roots of it and the
significance or how to
or how to
notice them even or how to create them
i think
synchronicities
are
again it's a reflective communication
process so
i don't know because i wasn't aware of
it i don't know that i had all kinds of
synchronicities 15 years ago
what i do know as i started noticing it
and as i started noticing it i would
start following the threads or the bread
crumbs
but as i followed the bread crumbs then
i would get more and more
synchronicities
so it was almost like the universe
communicating back to me here i was you
know i'm 53.
i at 42 years old started realizing i
can communicate with the universe
and it started out with a one-way
communication
and now it's becoming more of a
two-way street of communication
and i think as that occurs as you get
more of that two-way street you can
start interacting in different ways with
this communication and for me it started
out with mathematics because
math and number is you know the the
universal language yeah
of of of a construct and i
fundamentally believe that you know the
geometry has been all around us all the
time but if you don't stop if you just
get stuck in your day-to-day routine of
life you can easily miss all of these
things
but fundamentally i believe that we're
here to find and remember these things
in addition to learning how to transcend
judgment and learning to love and
replace
judgment with acceptance
overcome the first level is overcome
fear and separation
right as you break past that and replace
fear with gratitude then you start to
learn how to to non-judge and to observe
rather than judge and try to look at
different perspectives maybe the way i'm
seeing it is not the only way to see it
and that's when your mind really expands
and then the next step after that is to
realize that maybe the universe is
actually speaking to me maybe there is
some form of destiny
maybe i chose it
maybe this is a game i'm living
and and this is exactly what it's
referred to the heroes gamos
right the heroes gamos which doesn't
mean the hero's game it actually means
the alchemical wedding
but it is the that's sort of the the end
result of what the game of life actually
is sure go up to the seventh chakra
which is the the crown chakra and that's
why gender is the seventh
of the seven hermetic principles
it is the re recognition
that
you know while it's already described as
polarity gender is a basic aspect of
this universal experience yeah i think
what is everything is gender everything
has a gender and that's a reference to
this part of your brain called the cave
of brahman or even the wedding hall as
it's sometimes referred to
between the masculine and feminine the
pineal gland and the pituitary gland
and those two things come together
and all of a sudden you can now step
into a new level of consciousness which
is
no longer conscious versus subconscious
but it's actually integration of
subconscious and shadow
and that becomes the super conscious
mind
yeah i was having a conversation with
this
about this with zach bush you know zach
yeah yeah i was just with him at
aubrey's conference
okay i was i had dinner with him and we
were getting on this topic of
the masculine feminine and really just
like next like future future
relationship
which
is two things it's one with the self
with the masculine and feminine
and creating that balance and that
synergy and
um
sovereignty
but
then and he says like if you put two
people together
that both have that alignment with
themselves
it takes one couple
to transcend humanity that's right and i
was like
so
please elaborate your thoughts on that
i could not agree more in fact he said
the exact same words
verbatim
at the arcadia conference
okay
and and uh it was kind of an interesting
challenge i think he put out to the
crowd everyone's like who's the couple
it's pretty cool but i i really think
highly of of zach i mean he's uh he's a
profound uh thinker also but also huge
heart
and
what he's referencing is this notion of
the alchemical wedding
the alchemical wedding
in alchemy is the representation really
it's analogous or metaphor of the
masculine and feminine which is also
embodied in our own brains
it's the left and right brains now first
of all i don't believe our brain is a
i don't believe that it is a hard drive
storage unit
with ram and rom okay i believe that
it's a radio receiver
yeah and
we can change the tuning of that radio
hello what's your dog's name
her name is ella i think that she's
scared because there's a storm happening
and they never happen in arizona so i
don't know what kind of turbulence we're
creating right now but uh but it's a big
storm so she'll just sit there for a
moment i suppose
awesome so
so basically this idea of masculine and
feminine is really metaphorical to our
brains which are really processors
like a super super incredible processor
and radio receiver
and and we can tune our heart dial
to the frequency which then determines
what radio stations we're picking up
what frequency are we going to be
picking up so you could have the exact
same circumstance and if you're in a
high frequency mode you're going to see
the positive aspects of that thing
all the beautiful positive aspects
exactly what everyone else might be
going that's horrible what the heck this
is terrible when you're in a low
frequency mode you're going to see all
the negative aspects of that thing
this is our own conditioning biases and
particularly in today's world where we
all live in an ai echo chamber
we're going into i just wrote a book
called neuro mind
m-i-n-e-d we're all being neural mind
because the greatest or the most
valuable asset in the world now is no
longer oil
it's actually data yeah exactly and and
so as a result i wrote this book with
michael ashley who's a fantastic uh
person as well
and the book goes through this whole
story of how mankind is now being
subjected to this notion and maybe by
our own choice
right again in the context of this
mental matrix
being subjected to this notion of no
longer just selective disclosure but
selective exposure
i can see
now based on your habits and everything
else what things are going to elicit the
types of responses that give you the
most dopamine
so big tech is now the largest drug
dealer in the country yeah in the world
right they can determine they don't even
have to have fields they don't have to
like plant seeds of marijuana or
anything they can just play with your
own dopamine
and they can create and foster your own
dopamine and by the way why do they want
that dopamine they want that because the
more dopamine you get the more
engagement so
let's make sure that you only go to
websites or let's make sure you only get
exposed
to chat rooms that are aligned to your
way of thinking because as soon as you
hear someone else say something you also
agree with you're like wow i'm right
right and we're all narcissists in a way
look oh yeah we all have a little bit in
us or a lot look how many likes i have
and with that then
now they can get us on these apps longer
because we're like wow we get addicted
to look how many likes this got wow they
like me they agree with me
and this selective exposure is a a form
of mass propaganda and manipulation
but maybe experience what we're
experiencing right now to the highest
degree because it's the most we've ever
had of this data manipulation but the
way i look at this
is it's also a doorway
to probably an entirely new way of
humanity interacting with each other and
for themselves for the first time in
human history mankind is actually
creating value
without toil
think about that
so each of us just through our own
habits and behaviors
in our social time or whatever are
creating a ton of valuable data that's
unfortunately for us getting monetized
by somebody else so the original
producer is left out of it it's a
variable matrix
except that instead of providing energy
like a battery to the matrix we're
providing information
to the matrix
right
and that's then essentially controlled
by an oligopolistic group of you know
five or six companies really yeah
exactly that have control over that
narrative
yeah and they're looking at the world
from their own advantage point
not vantage point so when you look at it
in that context i look at it and say
well geez if this is the first time in
human history where mankind is creating
value without actually having to toil
for that value
is this not a potential opportunity for
human beingness over human doingness
is this we've been human doings for the
last few hundred
years can we now create something is
there a possibility of a universal basic
income that is truly
sustainable
and not built on a redistribution model
but rather if we all understood how
valuable our own data is
could we not monetize that on ourselves
on our own but what's the mechanism be
able to do that
well that's what
my companies have worked to build
which is like quantum resistant vpn
technology where you can encrypt all of
your data
and then sell it if you want or never
sell it
it's yours to sell
you are the commodity
you are your own system you are your own
ecosystem
data is an extension of who we are
think about that it's
my social profile is
is now part of who i am
right and if you're gonna take that away
because i could be deplatformed
then i cannot be the same type of or
could not have the same type of
experience as i once had
you know if you're going to take away my
soapbox by de-platforming me
because my narrative doesn't align with
yours
yeah then that could cause severe
distress for me
right
but i believe there should be a paradigm
where people should be able to i believe
in freedom of speech and i believe that
you know governments derive their just
powers from the consent of the governed
i believe in the the same principles
that went into the declaration of
independence we hold these truths to be
self-evident that all men are created
equal that they are endowed by their
creator with certain inalienable rights
that among these are life liberty and
the pursuit of happiness that to ensure
these rights governments are instituted
among men
deriving their just powers just powers
from the consent of the governed
this is something that i think we've
sort of lost
that's right there's not the consent and
or not a lot of conscious consent not a
conscious consent and the just powers
are no longer just
and that's what i think a lot of people
are going through right now but i do see
amid all of this a kernel i see a silver
lining and the silver lining is is that
there will be transformation coming
there will be change coming
and that change is badly needed and it's
going to be fitting with the new cycle
that we've just entered into right which
is
lovingly referred to as the age of
aquarius
yeah and and i think that's the shift is
the transcendence of duality into this
new age of acceptance technology
um
frequency understanding of frequency and
vibration oh my god yeah my opinion of
why we were here on this why are we here
what is the point was to experience
duality and then i had an event happen
that was really difficult and really
hard for me
in that experience because i just
thought sort of duality were two
different things it was just like the
good and the bad
and when i experienced that
it broke me open to really really really
happy joyful positive things as well as
the experience of what happened
and at that point i realized that
duality was a circle
like because they were connected
they weren't two separate things they
weren't even the ends of the spec they
were like connected they're inseparable
from each other now we're moving to a
third paradigm
just like binary code is going from you
know standard computing models into
quantum computing we're going from ones
and zeros in binary code to a third
position now which is the x position the
superposition it can be either a one or
a zero
right and i think this is part and
partial of how society is transforming
right and it's often represented by a
dragon in esotericism
this notion of this wheel of time the
aura boris the same realization that you
just had the snake eating its tail or
the dragon eating its tail
no you could look at duality like you
know arrogance and humility or
like you know dark and light and what we
realize actually when you start to get
deeper into it we're saying that you
know women are the negative pole and men
are the positive pole you know i kind of
come back to the question of which way
does the earth spin
does it spin counterclockwise or is it
clockwise and actually the truth is
that depends
it depends on your point of advantage
if you look at it from the north pole it
spins counterclockwise if you look at it
from the south pole
it spins clockwise
the reason why we say it spins
counterclockwise is because most of the
learning institutions on the planet are
the northern hemisphere so it's been
their advantage position
but actually the
who's to say what which one is the north
and which one is the south pole
what is the top side in space it doesn't
really matter right
so
it's a different way of looking at
things we can be stuck on this notion
and i use this example all the time of a
cylinder if i said to somebody you know
i'm holding a cylinder and it's this
flat circle right here and
to your perspective looking at me
and it casts a shadow on the wall behind
me and what you see is a shadow of a
circle
or
from the person sitting you know on the
other side of me
this direction you might actually see
i'm holding a square or a rectangle
because actually what i'm truly holding
is a cylinder
it's both
so neither of them are wrong
their answers are just incomplete about
what it actually is and what i have is
the higher perspective
of knowing that there's an additional
dimension
in three dimensions that says that it's
neither only a circle nor a square a
rectangle but it's actually both
and their answers are simply incomplete
because it's a cylinder so do you do you
think that it's actually
is it incomplete or incompatible with
new
with a new next level existence
frequency dimension
um awareness like i wonder i think about
like newtonian physics quantum physics
or and how math evolves and how
sometimes it's just not compatible
anymore and i wonder if as we expand and
grow our consciousness
and um
you know
reach a next level of existence and
awareness do we actually create
essentially like a whole new paradigm of
of math and of reality
yes
um and each time we do it provides
another axis of reference
so let's say we have a an x-axis right
like a horizontal plane then we have a
y-axis and now we're going to
create depth to that so now we're going
to take this two-dimensional view of a
square a rectangle and a circle and say
no no let's look at this in a third
dimension and it's going to have a depth
perspective so we need a z-axis now so
you've got
a line this way align this way and then
a line kind of coming down diagonal this
way
right
and as we go to higher dimensions each
one of these additional dimensions is
simply a 90 degree offset from the
others
so you can continue to add dimensions
well if we lived in a two-dimensional
world and an apple fell through our
world as flatlanders carl sagan does a
great review on this on
on youtube but if an apple fell through
our world what we would see we wouldn't
see an apple what we'd see is
sequential slices
of an apple falling through our world
well first of all we'd also have to
realize we don't have time
right there's not a time perspective in
that world in two dimensions
everything's fixed right as soon as you
have motion
and frequency you now have time so now
that z-axis creates a spinning vortex
right of rotation
that becomes the fourth dimension so we
have three dimensions of space three
dimensions of time
and therefore when you look at it each
one you have to see your point of
reference are you able to perceive in
higher perspective and higher dimension
because by the way unless you have
experienced that higher dimension you
can't even use words to describe that
higher dimension how would you even
describe depth if you'd never
experienced depth
right so this is the challenge that we
have and and i believe that
those things that we cannot yet see or
experience
like dark matter and dark energy
yeah you're probably just in higher
dimension yeah you don't understand it
yet maybe what we called random before
is not really random at all maybe it's
just our inability to perceive god's
encrypted pattern
sure because we don't have the right
vantage point maybe it isn't chaos maybe
it is organized in a different
different level
everything i believe is organized
it's just our boundary condition of what
we call entropy
is really the end of knowledge
and the beginning of ignorance and as we
grow and expand our conscious awareness
we push that boundary condition out
farther and farther and farther and it
grows at about the speed of light
because maybe the speed of light isn't
really the speed of light maybe it's the
speed of our perception
there was some words that came into my
awareness and i was listening to
something that had to do with time and
the words that came in and then they
started talking about it
um was that
time is entropy
yeah and that i wonder if time is just
some word we give we we think it's this
way in that way right but it's actually
just like a measure we use of entropy
well words matter
and if we take the word time so in greek
language
um
many many words have mirror reflective
properties so their anagram actually has
a meaning like the word aeon which is a
period of time like
2160 years would be referred to as an
aeon right usually
like an eon like eons
it's the greek spelling aeon we've
anglicized it to eon right okay but it's
the same thing okay so an aeon
backwards
is in no way
now aeon also means the aeons in
gnosticism also referred to gods
right
the gods of gnosticism are aeons
but it also can mean i am
right so what is no way no way the greek
word which is the just written backwards
right it's just the end
of aeon is no way and that means i think
from noetic sciences
so wait now you're telling me that aeon
is i am
and no way is i think i think therefore
i am
deep
right
it's a deep thought yeah so you got aeon
versus n
o
e a right i think
i am so rene descartes gave us that
great philosopher and mathematician and
physicist as well
but also someone who believed very very
strongly in the esoteric
and the mystic sciences
right maybe spirituality is just the
science we don't understand yet in
higher dimension totally agree with that
believe that for a long time
so now let's look at the word time
yeah what is time backwards
e emit emit
emit
so what is the term that we use
to reference light
we emit light
emits light the word laser is light
amplification of stimulated emission
of radiation
what is the opposite of radiation
emission
it's gravity
and time
so you have light
and you have dark
right what we've been referring to
sometimes people refer to it as
entropy this word i just don't really
love right that really just means
confusion or chaos or something we don't
understand
right that's because we don't really
understand time because the doorway into
the next higher dimension is
transcendence and understanding that all
dimensions of time exist simultaneously
i mean you can't deny that time and
gravity even
the the most reductionistic of
physicists would say that gravity and
time are directly linked together
they must be
right and why would they be linked
together you've seen the movie
interstellar and in the film
interstellar movie in the whole world
right you've seen the part where they
land on this planet that's close to
gargantua and the black hole and because
the gravitational force there is so
strong
they're there only 45 minutes
and 23 years pass on their ship which is
not that far away right
right so they come back to the ship the
guys at cryogenic freeze has been there
for 23 years waiting for them right
because there's something called time
dilation as a result of gravitational
force right of that the gravity
is causing this differential in time
time is different on the planet jupiter
because gravity is stronger than it is
on earth
that's why their jovian year you know
their cycle around the sun
if you were living there might actually
be closer to
the 11.86 years that it is for us which
is 4
320 days so when you look at this and by
the way that relates also to the 43 200
mile
radius that jupiter has
really same 432 interesting number
synchronicities there
you'll find that every planet in the
solar system actually relates to the
speed of light even
the speed of our earth going around the
sun
is exactly 10 000 times slower than the
speed of light
interesting
miles per second
um
i'm kind of obsessed with fractals which
i feel like is
also like
is partly patterns because i really
wonder about what reality is and what we
are and what we're doing and all these
things and
and i
i'm also friends with nasim so like i've
also heard very well hearing you know
from him and
in all of my research and curiosities
and listening to you too this week it
really kind of drove it home
it seems as though like i wonder if you
can actually find a pattern in
everything is there anything that
doesn't have a pattern that correlates
and if that's true
then one what are those things that
don't correlate or don't have a pattern
and if and if it is true
then
what does that say about our reality and
our consciousness because it feels like
there's something else
but yet when you think in the when i
think in terms of fractals and patterns
i think we're just a pattern and like
all this this all this this reality this
this whole thing is just a feedback loop
like now sim says it's just a feedback
loop and so what makes it unique or
special because there's something that
feels unique and special
from a consciousness standpoint so i
know i just kind of said a lot of words
and i'm going to shut up but those are
my random thoughts about fractals and
our reality and what the hell's really
going on i believe
and i don't like you know it'd be
impossible to prove this statement so
i'm not going to try to claim that it is
absolute fact but i fundamentally
believe
that
there
are only patterns
and because of dimension
of perspective that we can perceive
our limitation to see the depth of those
patterns
just like our ability to zoom out from
the tree that we're standing too close
to to see the forest yeah
we're so close to the tree we can't see
the forest and maybe we can't see even
the the town that it's close to or
adjacent to or the planet that it's on
right i i think of this as like
different stages of dimensional
experience let's say you're a
grasshopper you live in a field
you know and you think that your
universe is that field
you don't know anything more than that
that's your whole life your whole life
and gestation and everything your whole
life you know timeline is so truncated
super short but to you it seems like a
lifetime
it's all based on your perspective so
then you die and maybe you you go and
you come back in another life form maybe
now you're a monkey you live in a forest
or a jungle or something now you've got
expanded flora and fauna a
diversification of life forms that
you didn't experience when you're a
grasshopper
and then
now you still don't know however that
you might across the hill you know let's
say you're in a jungle in costa rica
there's a whole town and city over there
with human beings
those human beings might be as far away
because that could be in your context
light years away from you in distance
right and then you die and you come back
and you come back as someone who lives
in rural america who's never traveled
anywhere
and
who's watched things you know has
watched about going fishing in alaska
and seeing the sky how beautiful it is
but until they actually go there in
person they don't really know what it's
like to be in alaska
and then you might come back again this
time in a form that you're well traveled
like you've been all over the world you
know different cultures you've learned
different languages you have different
perspectives you have the perspective of
time and history maybe you didn't have
in the past life
and each time you're up leveling
consciousness and you're getting more
and more experiences of diversification
that diversity why is it then not
standing to reason that the next
experience you might have might be with
extraterrestrials
as you up level your dimensional
experience
and i think that's
maybe those extraterrestrials were here
all along
and they've just been in higher
dimension all along
we talk keep talking about a contact
experience
maybe that contact is already happening
with millions of people
on planet earth today who are
experiencing high dimensional
communication
and i can tell you i firmly believe that
i've experienced it myself
so the point being that i think
humankind is going through this
transformation stage right now
where we're up leveling consciousness
and the most important aspect is to
learn to transcend
all the constructs of this world if you
want to continue to be in this context
the way that it's always been and expect
a different result than we've gotten
then that's just the definition of
insanity not me talking about
extraterrestrials
right absolutely and and that's what
we've been experiencing patterns over
patterns over patterns and the universe
keeps throwing it at us until we finally
wake up it's like yo dude
i've been throwing you messages all
along
wake up
what i would say is the spiritual
awakening process you know and it's not
woke woke if you're still in the mode of
judging
that's not awakened
because it's like religion religion
organized religion tends to teach
judgment spirituality is teaching yo
dude you gotta look within
it's your own issues you're responsible
for your own experience you're not a
victim if you believe you're a victim
you're just going to continue to be
victimized in your world
yeah because that's the importance
that's the lens that you're going to
experience and i'm not meaning to
belittle what other people have
experienced than you know terrible
crimes and everything but i will say
this
that
90 plus of what we experience
is not in fact what we experienced is
what we believe we experienced yeah
and this happens day in and day out i'm
not saying there aren't bad people that
do horrifically bad things in the world
but what i am saying
is that the more we judge those things
the more they will come into our field
100
what we judge what we what we judge is
essentially what we deny and our reality
is trying to show us where we're not
whole
um
you talk you said that you've had
experiences i'm really curious what
those experiences have been um with
interdimensional beings
i want to start by saying we don't tend
to judge we don't tend to experience the
world
as it is
we tend to experience the world as we
are
right and
by the same token i went with nasim
to egypt in 2017
he invited me to uh to give a
presentation in like a keynote position
which was very
kind of him
to present on mathematics because i had
started to
you know really get deep into math i
went through a very difficult situation
a crisis situation where it caused me to
really question
my objective reality as we go through
the peak of our own narcissism
that is usually the doorway to spiritual
awakening
because we realize something is not
working right
right and and maybe what i'm
experiencing
is
self-imposed and self-inflicted
so you start to get to that stage and so
what it did is it caused me i
experienced betrayal i think you know i
came here one of the principles i wanted
to learn in this life was unconditional
love so
if you wanted to come here to learn a
principle
of unconditional love you will
experience
its opposite
it's opposite is betrayal
it's conditional love right you don't
feel betrayed by somebody you didn't
care about
yeah you don't even notice by someone
you loved
you didn't even notice if you didn't
care about them
yeah and and so i went through a very
very extreme case of of betrayal
and it was very difficult for me to
synthesize and process to the point
where i'm like wait a minute is all my
objective reality totally [ __ ]
i need to go back to the queen of the
sciences which is mathematics and i want
to understand
and question every single notion of
mathematics i'd previously had
does one plus one really equal to
or is it something altogether different
i actually reconstructed mathematics on
that basis
and out of that process i discovered a
prime number pattern and published it
and every time i've looked for patterns
patterns exist
so
basically you could think of it as
we could look at our own intelligence as
a species
based on the the degree to which we
perceive patterns
versus chaos
so think about that for a moment you
could call that like a a collective
conscious or a consciousness quotient
and you're talking about so
this is the way i'm receiving it
perceiving it
is that being able to
see patterns
would be like your own patterns like
someone that's at the brink of wanting
to feel unconditional love will get
a pattern of conditional love yes and
then eventually you go why
the [ __ ] am i only getting conditional
love all i want is unconditional love
and so you you notice that pattern in
your reality yes you're saying because
you continue to judge
conditional love so you will continue to
experience it it will be thrown at you
in your life over and over and over
again until you finally stop judging
conditional love and accept it and once
you accept it then you have now learned
the notion of unconditional love
because the thing that you came to this
earth and you thought i'm gonna be here
to learn i'm here to learn and
experience
unconditional love well when that is
your desire the thing that you desire
will always be elusive to you
for people that want money the ones that
are always feeling poor and scarce we'll
never find it they'll never find it it's
like they'll be searching for it and
searching for it and even when they get
it they lose it like that it's like it
falls like like water through their
fingers yeah whereas as soon as you
instead decide i'm already abundant
i'm already wealthy
that's the mindset that i embody it's
the watch no longer judge yeah and no
longer judge
the scarcity you see in others or in
yourself
then you will experience abundance
the universe wants to give us as soon as
we learn to accept those things that we
are triggered by so whenever we get
triggered and everyone today in today's
society is always completely like i'm
offended oh my god i'm offended
everything's in a fence you can't use
that word what the hell that's why
people like jordan peterson have taken
off so crazy you know in society because
he's like no this is [ __ ] stop it
and everyone's like that resonates holy
crap
right exactly it's like if you're
offended constantly that's your problem
that is your problem
get over it dude
like your first teacher is constantly
offended then you you are the hammer
that's per you know the proverbial
hammer constantly looking for the
perennial nail
and then everything looks like a nail
and by the way if you think that works
for you then go for it
but by the way you're not separate from
me you're just a reflection
exactly and i i have to learn how to
accept that too
that not everyone is going to accept
it's it is what it is
and being accepting of that
non-acceptance
is learning the love and acceptance it's
the same thing so you ask the question
about
you know higher dimensional experiences
so i gave a speech for nassim
at this conference and it was on
mathematics and the language of
mathematics because as i was
reconstructing math
which is this very objective science
right the most objective but by the way
also the most esoteric
what is numerology
yeah so again it's the circle
mathematics
is the most objective science amongst
reductionists but at the same time
amongst esotericists it's the most
esoteric
how does that work we're seeing numbers
oh we call these angel numbers or
numerology numerology is crazy accurate
if you get into that it's like it takes
astrology almost like to another level
of detail and dimension
i could put axes and say okay
there's astrology as a z-axis numerology
is a y-axis
a z-axis would be alchemy whoa
whoa totally
right so when you start thinking in
those terms i'm giving a presentation in
egypt in 2017 and october was right
after the big eclipse that was in it was
august or september of that year which
was a big awakening
eclipse and i remember i live in orange
county california and um
the percent of totality remember that
term totality the amount of coverage you
get
uh on the moon over the sun to create
the corona
so corona has been a word
that's been in the consciousness for
quite some time now isn't it it just
means crown
oh i was going to ask what does it mean
crown corona means crown so wait
coronavirus is the crown virus
oh is it a vibe at the seventh chakra
are we at the seventh chakra yeah
whoa
that's deep it's like wait it's a virus
spirituality is a virus
interesting or maybe it's a different
way of looking at things right so here i
was in uh in egypt and giving a
presentation on math as a language
language of the universe
and at the end i was only supposed to
talk for like two hours and it ended up
being like four hours because people
were asking tons of questions i was
stunned to find half the room in tears
oh man okay i've been there i've been at
his i've been there for a week long and
i'll tell you my experience at the end
but yep i don't i'm not surprised half
the room in tears
and
it was fascinating to me because i did
not expect that i'm like okay i'm
teaching about math as a language but it
was almost like you saw that movie
contact yeah yeah of course one of my
favorites a rival a rival
i've seen that too a rival with um the
redhead actress
amy adams amy adams yes she did i just
saw that actually he's a linguist right
and she's brought in to like communicate
with these seven-legged
like heptapods that are transcending
time
yes
remember that was sort of the whole
story yes and and nobody could
understand their language it was like
this these shapes it's like a geometric
language and then she had to learn how
to decipher it as a linguist and in the
process as she learned that language
she transcended time
yeah
there's a deep story within that for
herself though right for herself like
somehow learning the language because
remember in the very beginning she kept
having these flashbacks yeah exactly
and you realize later they weren't
flashbacks they were flash forward
forwards
right and it was like exactly
wow right so the whole thing was they
had to come back in time they're from
the future come back in time to correct
something you know for retro causality
and grandfather paradox and all that
stuff that goes along with it so that
you know
humanity could have this information and
help them in their hour of need
right and it was sort of a fascinating
premise but
you know she had this ability as a
linguist to learn this language
and so when i presented in egypt
i presented math as a language
that where the
the verbs and nouns
and syntax of the language can be
identified as
the nouns are just the numbers
the verbs are the mathematical constants
that have ing appended on the end of
them which are infinite tails of the
rationality
and they're verbs of action like i'm
going to take
i'm going to circle right a circle a
diameter and that's a verb of action
circling the diameter yeah therefore it
never ends it's like in french we say i
speak eight languages and jesus
i am in the train of doing something
it means i'm not finished with it it's
an incomplete action the circle never
completes right it's infinite
it's the same concept and then i looked
at it from the perspective also that how
is the syntax arranged it's arranged
in overlapping intersecting circles that
inscribe geometric forms within them and
those are the sentences
so as we start looking at math as a
language of communication with the
universe
we can start to communicate differently
with the universe
and for people that were there some of
them were like this is like a contact or
like a a rival experience for us
well that night
we went into the great pyramid
and after we were in the great pyramid
and i laid in the sarcophagus and found
the resident's frequency and the sim did
not let me leave he's like you got to
stay in here and do this because even
though my assistant was sick and she
wasn't feeling well the energy in the
pyramids really have you been there
before yeah i have yeah so energy is
really powerful
yeah super high frequency we were going
through like a whole it was like
something there's a book called uh
initiation by elizabeth hank
and worth reading and this whole process
it's a hermetic process the pyramid is
an ascension
device
it's about expanding awareness expanding
consciousness and remembering who you
are
that's what i really believe it's about
and so i laid in there i came out of
that
and i ended up going outside with a
bunch of my friends and colleagues that
were there about 40 or 50 of us and
we're laying on the
you know the limestone
which is in front of the great pyramid
we can still hear people in there like
making noise and chanting because it's
like a giant speaker right it's like
literally
in the morning it's like acoustically
designed
absolutely and we're laying out there
on the plateau there were no drugs
involved not at least for me but there's
like 40 people there and i look up and i
say
do you guys see what i see
and there were about 50 to 75 ships
above the giza plateau
doing formational shifts and changes
wow right
they were like these blue green
or large orbs
and
doing these
formations right above the giza plateau
and all of us saw it
do you think you saw them because they
showed up because of the frequency or do
you think you saw them because of your
frequency i think it was the latter
i think they're here all the time all
around and it's
only a function of our own frequency
that either allows us or disallows us to
see it and experience yeah man i've had
so many
super smart people starting with neil
degrasse tyson i was like do you think
that maybe we can't find
extraterrestrials like we don't see them
because we're looking for exactly like
us like are we supposed to be like maybe
they're not just like this you know
which would also imply maybe they're
dimensionally in a different dimension
that we don't have the we can only see
and hear in such a narrow spectrum of
the full spectrum
what makes you think that they're not
there just because we don't see them in
this sort of like through this lens
you know i think again we see the world
from our own point of advantage
and the world and the academic community
has become one
that really sees
spirituality and sciences juxtaposed
against one another when actually the
two are completely married to each other
and the circle that's right it's a it's
just a a narrow way of perceiving the
world and universe and i respect neil
degrasse tyson i think he's a very smart
guy but he's reductionistically smart
and he's he's married to a lower
dimension of thought
before he he lacks the wisdom
and perspective to see in a higher
dimension
and that is just
the nature of reductionism that doesn't
mean to say that he won't necessarily
eventually everyone does
but there are certain people that are
more married to the lower dimensional
perspectives and time is no different
once we start to learn
the buddhistic
taoist
approaches to overcoming our
attachment to duality
we start to experience time differently
that wasn't my only experience i've had
many experiences
right and
and actually it started when i was 11
years old
i was 11 years old i lived in rendelsham
forest
and there's a very famous incident of
ufos that were recorded by the uss
military that were basically referred to
as arcturian
who were
future humans
that came to visit and there were many
eyewitnesses to this one of them was a
fellow by the name of jim peniston a
book was written by gary osborne i lived
right on that forest
and i had experiences it was right after
christmas
on the 26th the 28th of december in 1980
and
here i was living there because my
father was in the military and this
happened on a u.s air force base
so
i had many experiences like this it's
always been in higher dimension they've
been here all along
it's not it's it's us that cannot see so
this is why i say that a new form of
quotient of intelligence maybe
from a universal perspective really
should be our ability to see in higher
dimension what is seeing in higher
dimensions being able to make sense of
patterns that exist
beyond the normal framework of the
dimension that you're within
so our ability to perceive pattern
versus randomness
might actually be the definition
of levels of
conscious quotient
i like that what about what is the what
is the role of frequency in that and
sound because definitely in the king's
chamber and in the pyramid it the
frequency is really high really high in
the king's chain i'm not like i don't
feel people's feelings but i can feel
frequency and that's what i noticed in
there was just just super high
vibrational frequency and it looks very
acoustic in there like walking up the
main shaft up it's like staged ceiling
that goes up and right there they're
gables that go there's like seven gables
and then right you know you've got if
you go to the the red pyramid
um yeah
in in desure i've been there too there's
13 gables right 13 cables so you've got
like kind of octaves like seven and
thirty oh yeah i mean we toned in all of
them we toned in the sarcophagus as we
toned in many sarcophaguses as well as
in the red pyramid and the great pyramid
i mean we toned for an hour to while we
were in there as everyone had their
chance of laying in sarcophagus
and i just wonder and i also wonder
about the
conspiracy around the tuning frequency
of 440 and 432 hertz and just what what
effect that has on us but how much you
think that your tuning not only comes
from figuring finding patterns but to
also put yourself in an environment
where
a pattern can
you can implement a pattern or you can
stay with a pattern like i think about
my house and having emf reducers in the
house and i play hertz frequencies at
night next to me like that's like i i i
care about that and i feel like
music is another vein of that so what
level of the of
us being able to see patterns but then
also what role does frequency play in
our ability to
shift dimensions
it plays a huge role
and actually when you understand that
the relationship of 432 so you talked
about 432 i just told you jupiter
is 43 200 mile radius oh yeah i told you
that the jovian year is 4 320 days
right interesting
the radius of the sun is 432 000 miles
it's 10 times the size of jupiter's
radius
right 432 squared is the speed of light
in miles per second
the pyramids base the great pyramids
base
in measured in something called the
royal egyptian qubit is 440.
and that's actually an interesting
number it matches up with the tuning
standard for a
in our musical tuning today
and that musical tuning today is also
referred to as equal temperament but
tuned to a 440 hertz
yeah when you actually notice and i i
went with the sim also to mexico
we were both made shaman of the toltec
indian tribe right
that takes care of the guardians of the
teotihuacan plateau
and i i hosted the days in teotihuacan
so i did a lot of mathematical work
while i was there for residence with
them a few years ago a lot of
mathematical work and i found
some really interesting and astounding
correlations between two places on earth
that should not be related at all to
each other
teotihuacan
and the giza plateau now the first most
obvious reference is they're both
matching the belt of orion the
constellation okay that's interesting so
you've got these three pyramids that are
kind of the main part of the structure
there's other structures there just like
there are on the giza plateau but
they're all matching this kind of belt
position
of yeah orion so that's kind of strange
okay number two is if you look at the
base
of the pyramid of the sun in tamwatuba
khan mexico
it turns out to be the exact same base
with as the great pyramid
huh what a coincidence
and the height
of the pyramid is 216 feet in mexico
what a coincidence also
and is that also a coincidence then that
menkari pyramid the smallest pyramid on
the giza plateau is likewise 216 feet
high
that's interesting
so
and how many inches are there in 216
feet
2592
inches that's the length of the
procession of equinox divided by 10
25 920 years so but wait the mexicans
right that somehow the people the
indigenous peoples there
that built the teotihuacan plateau
somehow
used the same measurement systems that
the future uses that didn't even exist
at that time how do you connect those
dots and how does that relate back over
to the giza plateau
what about the pyramid of the moon in
mexico the pyramid of the moon
its base is the same height
as the great pyramid
so wait the pyramid of the sun has a
base that's the same as a great pyramid
and the pyramid of the moon
has a base that's the same as the height
of the great pyramid
this seems awfully coincidental doesn't
it yeah i mean well there's just too
many times the same numbers show up and
these are ran different places different
civilizations
different timelines
yet
you know we'll just add one more stone
and it doesn't add up so let's assume we
put in place
a hypothetical measurement
and that hypothetical measurement tends
to be this convergence of all these
different base widths and heights and
everything it comes out to 432
okay for the base of the great pyramid
this would be a long qubit
432 long qubits is the base
that's measured in long qubits
and then that means that the height to
the center of the great pyramid is
137.5098
which is the golden angle
that's the golden angle
so then double that you've got 275 long
qubits
and then you notice that that relates to
432 mencare the smallest pyramid is 216
feet
and by the way its base width
is
172.8
which is
exactly
4 or 8 times 432 divided by 10.
so again it's the same 432 patterns
you're a pattern maker
that's right and pattern realizer so
then the height of mankari
relates back to 432 it's just half of
432 just like the pyramid of the sun is
the same 216.
then let's look at caffrey cafe is the
middle pyramid a lot of people think
it's the tallest it's because it's on
higher ground it's like 33 feet higher
ground than the great pyramids on
so it looks like it's higher but it's
not really a bigger structure
it's 471 feet approximately or 144
meters
so it's exactly 144 meters
and the base width is 216 meters
there it is again so wait menkari is a
foot measurement
caffrey is a meter measurement
the great pyramid is a long qubit
measurement all relational to 432.
so
what is this telling us and you can
check the map
math is the math it's the beauty of math
what it's telling us i believe
is
that
this higher dimensional perspective this
frequency and
is very much tied to
how we perceive the world around us this
is the tetractus
the detractors of pythagoras is based on
four dots followed by three dots
followed by two dots and one dot four
three two
one four three two one and what does
that come out to
four times three times two times one
equals 24 which is what the prime number
pattern's based on
and four plus three plus two plus one
equals ten so now you've got
1 or 10
and 4 you know 4 3 2 1 is coming out to
24
these numbers are all fundamental the
most important what's the most important
mathematical constant you know
pi
pi right
golden ratio volume ratio pretty
important i'd say pi is definitely in
the math community pi probably trumps it
right pi probably trumps it
speed of light i don't know the second
most important mathematical constant
would probably be either the golden
ratio or maybe it's actually
the euler number
so the euler number is what controls
interest compound interest
so when you go to a bank and you get a
loan and they issue compound interest
for that no matter how much or how many
times they compound that interest it
hits a limit they'll never be able to go
beyond 2.71
so one is the principle of your loan
right it's the amount of money right
that
is the loan value but left they
compounded it like at the maximum number
of times possible the return would only
hit a maximum of 2.718 and all banks use
this math it's the it's the governor of
all wave
and expansion of exponential growth so
the governor of the universe
is really the speed of light we think
about light speed is like the speed
limit of the universe but what's the
speed limit of the speed limit it's
actually the oil number i've never heard
about the euler number i heard about you
saying that in an interview and i was
like what i've never heard of this yeah
and what's crazy about it too is euler
wasn't even the guy who discovered it it
was discovered that's a guy by the name
of leonard euler's a swiss mathematician
but the guy who discovered it was isaac
newton
isaac newton discovered it because of
his work to understand the great pyramid
and the euler number was related to the
royal egyptian cubit
which is 1.718 feet
if you add one foot to that
so the cubit plus the foot equals the
euler number
so six feet which is a fathom six feet
fathom
minus the euler number equals the meter
what
there's like order and pattern to all of
this there's not supposed to be order
and pattern to this you're telling me
that six feet which was a standard unit
of measure of a fallon measuring depth
how do i fathom the universe right which
might actually just be father and mother
moder fodder
so fathom
f-a-t-h-o-m mother backwards right
holy schnikes so you take six feet you
subtract the euler number you get the
meter
or six feet minus the meter equals the
euler number really
and where does the word euler come from
in the first place euler in german means
owl well guess how much an owl's head
will turn on its axis because you know
owls can turn your heads all the way
around about 271 degrees
which is the same number
interesting isn't it
271 or 272 degrees is the turn of the
axis of this owl's head so they've been
named at the owner it actually makes it
easier to remember the euler number
so and actually what is an owl
synonymous with wisdom
is the thing that makes squares scalar
waves it makes compression
and by the way
euler to the power of pi
equals
1 over 432
it really makes me wonder what we what
is this react when it's all just pattern
i really wonder what the true
significance of anything is maybe it's
that everything is super significant
but i really wonder like are we just
some
we're just a pattern
yeah it's like are we just an ai
yeah
maybe i mean i wonder that too are we a
simulation you know that's for sure a
question you could make strong arguments
to that effect and i wouldn't be the
first i believe fundamentally again you
have to come back to what it is that
we're here to learn and putting yourself
in the context of those other
frequencies i think can be a powerful
thing i i wanted to look at it
geometrically and said okay if we listen
to 432 hertz music
in just tuning pythagorean tuning
which was developed also by pythagoras
that long ago he said a should be 432
is 440 a little out of tune like that's
the conspiracy that i heard is that 440
is not as in resonance with the natural
frequencies and so is 432
is 440
an out of tune frequency i would say
it's
out of consciousness okay because that
the the conspiracy goes to like germany
and like changing the tuning to 440 it
kind of muted all the people it made
them a little bit less
reactive and energetic the reason
rational thought behind it is that
all geometry so i looked at this purely
from a geometric perspective so if you
look at the geometry of every polygon so
let's just start by looking at this
so what's the first polygon it's a
triangle right and what's the sum of
angles of a triangle it's 180 degrees
so then what's the next one it would be
a square so you go from three sides to
four sides and what is the sum of angles
of a square 360 degrees so it's two
times 180.
what's the sum of angles of a pentagon
which would be the five-sided object
540. so you've got you know five
angles and each one is at 108 degrees so
540.
so then you go to the next one which is
a hexagon hexagon is 720
okay so you've got 120 degrees each
and you've got six of them so now you're
at 720. you go to an octagon and an
octagon is going to have 1080 1080 is
the sum of its angles right it's 135
degrees times eight so you're now at
1080 and then you end up at the next one
which would be you know a a nine sided
or a nonagon each one of these if you
add them all up
what are these sum of all these numbers
so you've got 180 you've got 360 you've
got 540 you've got 720 you've got 1080.
what's the common thread that connects
all these numbers
something very interesting well one plus
eight for 180
plus zero equals nine
three plus six plus zero for 360 for the
square equals nine
five hundred forty five plus four plus
zero equals nine tesla
720
seven plus two plus zero equals nine
three six nine three six nine right
ten eighty one plus zero plus eight plus
zero equals nine and you'll find that
every geometric form without exception
infinitely
as you go up and up and up will always
sum to nine without exception
now that means to say
that since music is just
the geometry that we experience with our
ears
and geometry is just the music we
experience with our eyes
then shouldn't it stand to reason
that there should be
a similar convention
for music now let's try this for a
second what if we convert
those polygonal shapes those basic
polygonal shapes or polyhedra we could
go to polyhedra it works also
let's say we start with the note
and we tone it at 180 hertz instead of
180 degrees
that would be an f sharp
we go to the next note
it's also an f sharp 360 because that's
just doubling an octave
let me go to the next note
540
hertz that becomes a c sharp then we go
to the next note and let's play the next
what's the next note it's going to be
720 that's another f sharp
let's go to the next note
and now we're at 1080 and that's another
c sharp and as you go to the next ones
and follow that this whole thing will
make a perfect
f sharp major chord
in and they kind of got the chakras too
because as i have behind me all kinds of
crystals crystal bowls
they i would listen to them as like got
in you know like literally got into a
meditative space state let these bowls
play to me and i would
say kind of yes or no and i would just
give feedback i didn't know what to do
but i was like oh wow i felt that my
heart wow and sure enough where i could
feel the note was where the note
correlated with the chakras
absolutely
and because your bodies are just like
you know i have these singing bowls
and i you know these large crystal balls
one of them is an is an f
and it's a heart chakra bowl
and i'm playing this bowl and i notice
my piano starts playing a note
for your heart you're going to feel it
in your heart you play the note for the
crown chakra at a bull you're going to
feel it in your crown you're going to
feel it inside your brain
right each one of these are like musical
instruments in a way and they're
vibrating in sympathetic resonance
so the point is that now i just showed
you
that and there's a great film that i
helped executive produce on this called
sonic geometry that basically shows
that geometry is just music
in a visible form
so now now that we've made that
correlation
let's listen to how the music sounds
well when you listen to the music in
just tuning it doesn't sound fabulous
these chords like the ones i just said
do they sound just fine but the way it
gets corrected by pythagoras is
something called the pythagorean comma
so the pythagorean comma is an
adjustment that's made so that you can
use this scale across many many
different types of music and keys
i'm originally a musician so
what i then looked at was well maybe
that's not the right way to do it
maybe that's not the right way to do it
at all
maybe it's more related to these math
constants of the circle in the square
euler and pi so then i took that and i
said well
what if i change the major third
interval from 1.25 which is 5 over 4
interval
to 1.26 because i was following a thread
inside the vitruvian map by leonardo da
vinci in the upper right hand corner of
the page
the man standing like this
it has a pagination which says one two
six
so something told me
maybe i should apply that to the major
third
and see what happens to all musical
tuning when i do that do i still need a
pythagorean comma to correct for it and
i called this precise temperament tuning
and what i found is that when i did that
along with a perfect fifth at 432 hertz
and then apply that same thing all the
way through
then all the numbers come out to adding
up to nine
of course all the decimal positions on
them create like a blockchain of the
undertone series in overtone series
that are already embedded within the
note
and
all of it comes into perfect alignment
with the least amount of beatings that
you could ever hear that's when you have
two notes that are close together and
they go da
they're out of tune right
more so and and it's funny because i did
it purely geometrically
i use the 1.26 as the approach which is
the cube root of two because you can't
double an octave with a major third with
1.25 because 1.25 to the third power
would only get you
just shy of doubling the octave so it
always sounds out of tune
so by making this adjustment to the 1.26
it gives you the cube root of 2 it shows
that you can create all musical scales
based on three over two
for the perfect fifth and the cube root
of two which is another way of looking
at three over two
for the major third you combine that
you've got now precise temperament
tuning
and now musicians and people are able to
tune off of because people who followed
my work wanted to debunk it
and found that it sounded amazing
and that the san francisco you know
conservatory was even played and uh uh
jason martino who's a you know phd
musician
uh basically programmed it and it
sounded great and he was like whoa this
is like different
and and it's based on 432 but it's
precise now it's not using equal
temperament which is like a cookie
cutter approach to music it's more like
a snake
so the intervals are very slightly
different so you get more nuance but it
sounds really really good and i
encourage you to go check it out precise
temperament tuning i did it purely from
a mathematical theoretical perspective
yep
precise temperament tuning and you can
listen to jason martin knows got a lot
of tracks you can go to my website also
robert edwardgrant.com and if you just
scroll down on the front page you'll
find precise temperament tuning click on
that and there's all kinds of examples
of of the music of it but i think we're
entering into it's so brilliant a new
thank you so thank you it's a new
consciousness once we can start to
realize the power of this 432 it's
recognizing the divine
into the earth i think we're moving from
this duality which is yin yang
into yin shen yang shen is represented
by the x it's like alpha chi omega
if you think of it in those in those
terms and what that means is that
it's this non-dual perspective moving
away i mean we live in this world of
extreme polarity right now and are we
going to go into some kind of crazy
civil war conflict or whatever who knows
what's going to happen with this
election but i think there's going to be
some of us that are going to be in this
middle is it like the woo like the
middle way like in taoism it's the
middle way
the middle way
and that's the non-dual way
okay so all right i'm gonna have to
ask one last question here and let you
go
so
just to give us a call to action
essentially what is
what is the point
of our experience here
i believe that we come here to
experience and learn not through
didactic learning but through
experiential learning
i believe that we come here with certain
karma certain things that and
conditioning biases and you know you
could say that karma in a way in this
context of a mental universe is more
like a conditioning bias
and what we're here to learn is how to
fully love and accept ourselves in
whatever circumstance we find ourselves
and when we can learn to love and accept
ourselves i i fundamentally don't
believe that the world's a tough place
because people hate each other i believe
it's a tough place because people hate
themselves once we can learn how to love
and accept ourselves then that love and
acceptance express and permeates through
all of your life and experience then we
can start to
learn how to be the change we want to
see in the world if you want to
experience joy then be the joy if you
want to experience love then be that
love
you know and this is what aubry and i
were just talking about and he was i was
quoting him on this podcast thing that
he did
i really like that mentality because it
is about being the change you want to
see in the world
and realizing that if you don't like the
world experience you're experiencing
then look within and
transform your perception of both
yourself and the world around you and
that world will change when we change
the things we see change
exactly and when we change the way we
see things
we change and the world change it's a
loop yeah totally oh it's all a loop
right it's all a loop and it's it's very
exciting because this is probably the
best time in the last few thousand years
to be alive as we're transitioning to
this new framework of human thinking and
perception and it's a higher order
perspective and so what's going to
happen is you're going to see so many
systems whether they be you know all the
self-appointed arbiters government
university education
i just saw an article that said that
kids matriculating out of high school
into colleges are down at an alarming
rate
yeah because it's like people are like
all of a sudden it's not vibing for them
this box i don't fit i don't fit so
people are like rebelling against it so
there needs to be new mechanisms
for learning seeing things in
non-binary ways
right and i and i think that's why it's
reflecting around us too we're seeing in
the world around us that you know it was
funny i saw bill maher said geez this is
alarming if the the numbers continue
like everyone in the united states will
be non-binary or or you know a member of
lgbtq
right in the next few years like we're
all going to be gay and it was pretty
funny because
i was laughing and i thought to myself
well why are we seeing so much of this
reflected in society and i think it's
because it's a reflection of how we
think again it's a u inverse
we're starting to move out of this
binary zone of ones and zeros
into this
x superposition which really represents
super conscious thinking
and it's the integration of the
masculine and feminine it's the optic
chiasm which is right you know the left
brain connects to the right eye and the
left eye connects to the right brain
and
and the left brain becomes the alpha and
the and the right brain becomes the
omega
and the two can work together they don't
have to fight with each other they work
together this
recognition of the power of the omega
aspect the power of the right brain the
intuition the seat of irrationality the
beauty of irrational
like thought the beauty of what it means
to be a woman right the the curve the
the line all of those things work in
perfect complement one with another
and when we see it that way
that is the rise of the feminine thank
you robert wow i mean so much to soak in
i feel like i'm going to listen to this
interview about five times
um and i hope other people do too
because i think there are some people in
the world that
are a little further along and have have
done this a few times and are here to
anchor new realities and new timelines
and new levels of consciousness and so i
appreciate that you
i appreciate that you come back to the
fringe to bring us along you know
because
it's really helpful because it's about
kind of just it's about having some
words spoken that are just beyond
awareness or comprehension that help to
start
pulling us along and anchoring something
new so
you definitely speak to that and um
thank you for sharing and
i hope that i can convince you to be on
my podcast i have a whole bunch of
questions for you as well oh i would
love it so if you wouldn't mind
returning the favor i would i think it
would be powerful for a lot of people to
hear
the journey that you're on it would be
my pleasure my honor
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today i hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the subscribe button